-Thank you so much
and welcome,
welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
This is it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, President Trump
has been trying everything
to overturn the election,
and he finally got
one of his cases to
the Supreme Court.
Let's see how that went.
-The Supreme Court
has shut down
one of President Trump's
latest and last attempts
to overturn the election.
In one short sentence, the Court
denied a Republican challenge
to the vote in Pennsylvania.
-That is amazing.
They rejected Trump's whole
argument in one sentence.
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty much
the Supreme Court's version
of responding to a long text
with "K."
[ Laughter ]
One sentence.
That page had less ink
than Rudy Giuliani's face.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rim shot ]
That's basically a tweet that
went to law school.
It is the equivalent of a judge
taking off his leather glove
and slapping you with it.
[ Slap ]
"You fool!"
All of the justices were like,
"We put on our robes for this?
Wha--"
The Court really tried to do
Trump a favor though.
They figured
if it was one sentence,
he would actually read it.
[ Laughter ]
For Trump, it felt like
applying to college
and getting back
a thin envelope.
It is like, "Well,
this can't be good."
[ Laughter ]
Trump isn't giving up though.
He's like,
Now it's time to appeal to
an even higher court,
the Jedi Council.
Dear @Mandalorian..."
[ Laughter ]
The other big news is that
after testing positive
for COVID,
today Rudy Giuliani
was discharged
from the hospital.
Yeah. Another day, another
Rudy discharge.
-Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
-That is right, America's
Mr. Bean is back in action.
Giuliani didn't waste any time
embarrassing himself.
He waved good-bye to the doctors
wearing a gown
that was open in the front.
He was like,
"I was just tucking it in."
[ Laughter ]
But the hospital staff doesn't
have faith in Rudy.
On his way out, he grabbed
a Dunkin' Donuts napkin
off of the ground
and blew his nose in it.
It's like, "Hey, guy."
That's right, the nurses are
thrilled Rudy is gone.
Now they don't have to keep
changing his head pan.
[ Laughter ]
That's a great joke, yeah.
Yeah, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
President Trump's lawsuits
continue to be thrown out.
People are starting to get
the COVID vaccine.
Joe Exotic asked Kim Kardashian
to help him get
a presidential pardon.
And workers
at a New York City Chipotle
are fighting off
a horde of rats.
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It is time for "News Smash."
[ Applause ]
♪♪
First up, Trump's lawsuits,
they're not going well.
The Supreme Court just dismissed
the GOP's attempt
to overturn the election
in Pennsylvania.
So I'm sorry, Mr. President,
you tried your best,
but it just
wasn't effective.
But you know what is effective?
The COVID vaccine.
It's making the rounds
in England
and things are looking
promising.
I got to say it is nice
to get some good news for once,
instead of news that
completely melts your brain
and makes you feel insane.
Speaking of which,
Joe Exotic asked Kim Kardashian
to help him
get a presidential pardon.
Joe's in prison for trying to
murder Carole Baskin.
But he wants to get back to his
life of wrangling tigers.
I mean, if we wants to wrangle
large, furry beasts,
he could always apply for a job
at Chipotle.
[ Laughter ]
A location in New York City
is struggling to deal with
a horde of giant rats.
It's gotten so bad that four
employees have been bitten.
That's not good.
They should probably all
get vaccinated.
The U.S. will start giving out
COVID vaccines soon.
And the people that are first
in line to receive them are,
of course, elderly people with
underlying health issues.
People like President Trump.
[ Laughter ]
All three of Trump's
Supreme Court nominees voted
against his cause this week.
Losing all those cases has
got to sting,
kind of like when
you get bitten by a rat at work.
They are chewing through wires
and nibbling on avocados.
It's basically
a Chuck E. Chipotle in there
and the workers don't stand
a chance.
You know who else doesn't
stand a chance?
Joe Exotic.
[ Laughter ]
Kim Kardashian isn't going to
save you, man.
But hey, it was worth a...shot.
[ Laughter ]
In conclusion, I don't think
it's going to work out.
I don't think it's going to
work out.
I think it's going to work out.
I would not work there.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Well, some news from overseas.
In Russia they're telling people
not to drink alcohol
for almost two months
after taking the Russian
vaccine.
Russians heard it and were like,
[Russian accent] "We'll take our
chances with the virus.
[ Laughter ]
You know it is serious because
Russia does not even give
that warning to pregnant women.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, President-elect Biden
is busy with the transition,
and today, I read he's thinking
about making Pete Buttigieg
the ambassador to China.
Buttigieg heard and was like,
"Yes, please send me to Wuhan
where it is safer."
And apparently, Biden told
Buttigieg, "Take it from me,
if you work hard, you can be
President in 50 years."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the ambassador job
is way better
than the one Trump
offered him --
White House Elf on the Shelf.
[ Laughter ]
Here's some tech news --
Google just released
their breakdown
of 2020's most searched topics.
No surprise, number one was
coronavirus.
And number two was
election results.
But they also released a list
of their least searched terms.
The stuff that nobody Googled
all year.
Check this out.
Number five was
sourdough stopper.
[ Laughter ]
Interesting. I did not know
that was a thing.
The fourth least searched term
was
Facemasks with Mitch McConnell's
chin on them.
[ Laughter ]
Number three was just
Mank nudes.
[ Laughter ]
Number two was, How much
to hire the law offices
of Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
And the number one least
searched thing in 2020
was WAP sheet music
for church choir.
Well, that's -- that's --
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
That's really more of
an organ song.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I saw that Waze
has a new feature
for the holidays where you can
have Santa's voice
give you directions...
which sounds fun until your kids
hear their dad snap at Santa.
"All right,
I heard you!"
It's actually just a mall Santa,
so every now and then
you'll hear...
[Belches] "50 feet.
Explain to me why my wife
let me."
Guys, we have exactly
eight shows left
before we go on
Christmas break,
Which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It is time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Eight days left ♪
-That's right, every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving one
lucky audience member
a glorious Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to Christmas
Cabinet.
Now since there are eight shows
left, let's open
door number 8.
[ Drum roll ]
Ooh, all the way up top.
Oh, yeah. Look at that.
Love it.
Wow. That is gorgeous.
♪♪
That is nice.
A bird.
Wow.
That is just beautiful.
There is -- it's like a
turtleneck inside the sweater.
It's gorgeous.
Is that a couple partridges
in there?
Ooh, on the back,
a dancing lady,
like a St. Pauli girl, yeah.
Not an ad. Not an ad.
But we -- How many birds
you got on there?
One, two, three -- you got
three partridges.
It's not a pear tree.
But you get the idea.
Guys, let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll
please?
[ Drum roll ]
237!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Nice.
Nice to see you, bud. Hey.
Thank you so much for
being in our audience tonight.
What is your name and where
are you from?
-Carmine.
Originally from Brooklyn,
but live in Staten Island now,
make bad decisions.
-Hey, why not?
Hey, please, we love --
[ Laughter ]
Now you're wearing
a nice, warm fleece there.
But I think that this would
work out perfect.
What do you think?
-I think so. I think so.
I'll go with tree front.
-Yeah, sure.
Again, these sweaters
have no front or backs.
This year, everyone's guessing
what the front and back is.
Oh, look at this already.
I feel --
Oh, I feel -- This is --
Oh, look at this.
No, that's what I'm talking --
That --
Turn around and let's
see the front.
There you go.
Perfect.
Oh, my God. Fantastic.
Thank you so much.
Let's give our winner a round
of applause once again.
Thank you to our lucky
audience member.
We'll be right back with
Jon Hamm, everyone.
Come on back.
Ah, it's beautiful.
♪♪